- Well, welcome, everyone.
Thank you very
much for coming out
in the slightly chilly weather.
My name is Alyssa Goodman.
And I'm the
co-director for science
here at the Radcliffe Institute.
And so I welcome you also
on behalf of Radcliffe.
Some of you may have been
here earlier this year
for our annual--
well, last year now
for our Annual Science
Symposium on the Undiscovered.
And the theme of
the undiscovered,
for those of you
who were not here,
has to do it's not completely
by accident or serendipitous
scientific discoveries,
but discoveries
that are made when you have a
plan for what kind of science
you want to do.
But then you find something
you didn't exactly expect,
but you are very prepared.
And so Dan Kammen, who you're
going to hear from today,
will talk about that kind
of work a bit in the context
of energy research
and potentially,
hopefully, saving the earth.
And so, it falls
to me to tell you
about Dan, which I will
do in just a minute.
But also to mention
that there are
two more talks coming up well
within a week in this series.
So, we have one on
Friday and one on Monday.
And they both have
a life science bend.
And the information is
on the Radcliffe website.
And so if you haven't
registered for those, two more
talks in the undiscovered
series-- one Friday and one
Monday.
I should also mention that the
first few rows here are filled
with people-- the reason I'm
wearing a name tag today,
is that as another
activity at Radcliffe,
we're having a two-day seminar,
small seminar on trying
to marry data science approaches
and climate research across all
fields--
law, business, economics,
earth science, health.
And we'll let you know how
that comes out hopefully
at another event in the future.
But one of our participants for
that is my friend Dan Kammen.
And so, Dan Kammen
and I first met
when we were both
graduate students here
in physics in the late 1980s.
And-- yeah, Dan looks
younger than me, though.
But anyway, so Dan, like I said,
we both got degrees in physics.
And then Dan's path
diverged fairly quickly,
where he got more
and more interested
in energy and energy policy.
So, he has also an undergraduate
degree in physics from Cornell.
And then he went on and
did postdocs at Caltech,
and came back to Harvard.
And then he went to Princeton
as an assistant professor.
But for the last 20 years,
he's been at UC Berkeley.
And the list of
titles that Dan has
doesn't even fit on the page
that I have in front of me.
So I just selected some to give
you some taste of what he does.
He's currently the class of
1935 Distinguished Professor
of Energy, the chair of the
energy and resources group
there.
He's also appointed
in the Goldman
School of Public Policy in
the Department of Nuclear
Engineering.
He's the founding director of
the Renewable and Appropriate
Energy Laboratory, the
co-director of the Berkeley
Institute of the
Environment, the director
of the Transportation
Sustainability Research Center.
I left some off.
He's very lazy, as you can see.
And he's founded
or is on the board
of more than 10 companies.
And some of you may
remember his name
from the newspapers
and the news because he
has advised the Obama
administration, and the World
Bank, and extremely briefly the
Trump administration on energy
and sustainability issues.
He also was the
coordinating lead author
for one of the IPCC reports,
the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change.
And you may remember that Al
Gore and the rest of the panel
won the Nobel Prize
for their work in 2007.
So, because Dan
shared that prize
with so many other
authors in addition
to Al Gore, who
got half the prize,
he told me I'm allowed
to call him a micro Gore.
So, also you may have seen Dan.
When you see him, he
might look familiar.
He's been on many, many
television programs.
And in particular, he
hosted a six-part series
for the Discovery Channel
called Eco Opulus.
And so, I'm going to stop
taking Dan's time away.
And just say that I'm really
excited to hear him tell us
about an energy plan that
the earth can live with.
And the plan is that
we'll hear from Dan.
And then we'll take
questions at the end.
And there'll be a
microphone in the aisle.
And when you'd like
to ask a question,
please do come to
the microphone.
And thank you very much.
And thank you for coming, Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, thank you all for
being here on what for,
now a Californian, feels like
a very, very cold evening.
So, I really appreciate
everyone getting here.
I have to say though that
I feel even more of attuned
with the undiscovered
path because you
can tell a fairly
good story about what
I've done afterwards.
But at the time, I came to
Harvard to do cosmology.
I actually transferred here.
I won't get into that right now.
But I got here.
And then I got seduced
into studying neuroscience
and the evolution of the brain.
And it's actually the
complex systems part
that I feel like has
been the most useful
in the work I've done.
And I hope that that
kind of appears as we go.
But it's a story you can
tell the ties afterwards.
But I sure cannot tell a
coherent story at the time.
It was a interesting
wander through a lot
of very nice, benevolent
neglect along the way.
And so right now,
we're at a point
though when we need to do much
more than benevolently neglect
the planet.
And so I'm hoping these will
tie together a little bit.
I mean what I'll try to do is
to give a bit of an introduction
to my laboratory because
the way that it functions is
critical to the mixture between
basic science, applied science,
and engagement with a variety
of non-governmental groups,
and governments, and
others along the way.
And I'll use that to really
look at how quickly the energy
system of the world
not only is changing--
not always for the better--
but the ways in which we
critically need it to change.
And so this is
the part that will
bore the experts in the room.
And I apologize
just a little bit.
But really, to use
that to look at what
are we learning about how to
guide and steer innovation
for a decarbonised world.
And that's really when I get at.
What I find exciting is that
we, like all academics say,
all hard problems
we haven't solved,
we are waiting for the
younger generation to solve.
And I do remember
when I felt like I
was one of those
younger generation
folks-- which I do not anymore.
And right now, we
are at a point where
the 15-year-old Swedish
school children,
and young 29-year-old
members of the US
House of Representatives,
and a variety of others
are absolutely doing
exactly what we say,
in a very casual way,
those sorts of changes.
So, I'll end with this call
for a just transition, which
is probably a more accurate
title than Energy Plan
that the World Can Live With.
Because it's not clear
that the world is
going to be too
happy with the energy
plans that we are creating.
So, I'll jump into our
lab for a second just
to give a feel for it.
It's quite a diverse
group of individuals,
lots of different
backgrounds and interests.
And it's quite international.
It's really quite diverse.
And so, there's a
lot of approaches.
Most of the people that find
their way to this energy
and resources group came
out of a STEM background.
But increasingly, we have
people from philosophy,
and rhetoric, and a variety of
other areas as part of the mix.
And it's been
really heartwarming
to see the number
of people who feel
like they have a
huge input on how we
think about energy innovation.
And it's not just the kind
of the material science,
and physics, and chemistry
world that I sort of
assumed when I founded the lab
would be the main pieces of it.
So, anything that I'll
talk about today--
the slides from today's
talk, the papers,
and things that I'll
mention, the video clips--
they're all available on
the RAEL website, Renewable
and Appropriate
Energy Laboratory.
And you do need to type into
Google more than just RAEL.
Because if you just
put it in RAEL,
you will get the RAELians, who
claim to have cloned a human 10
years ago in Florida.
Haven't heard a lot
from them since.
So, my name, or Berkeley,
or something like that.
And then the Twitter is
not vacation pictures.
We try to post about
one tweet today.
Today was a bit
heavy, for reasons
I'll get to in a little
bit, about the work
from the laboratory.
So, RAEL has existed since
I moved from Princeton
to Berkeley 20 years ago.
It's actually when John Holdren
had departed here to Harvard.
And so there was a spot
available for an ex,
or former, or something
sort of physicist.
So, we've been working since.
And the big project we worked on
for the first couple of years,
and Lisa mentioned,
was that I've
been part of the IPCC team.
It actually started when
I was here at Harvard
under a NIGEC Northeast Regional
Center for Climate Change
fellowship in the 80s.
And then in the 90s
who worked really hard
on a lot of the
climate assessment,
detection of
climate change work.
The big benefit was that
we got this wonderful--
I got to share in
the Nobel Peace
Prize, which was wonderful.
But I don't know how
critical it is here
at Harvard, but at Berkeley
getting the check is great.
But as you know, if
you're part of a big team,
you don't get the
Nobel Prize check.
You get this nice plaque.
But you do get something much
more valuable at Berkeley,
and that is a parking space
with a big large "NL" on it
for Nobel Laureate.
And I was really waiting
for my parking space
to impress my friends and
and sort of annoy my enemies.
Nothing happened the first
year, 2007, 2008, 2009, nothing,
nothing, nothing.
Finally, a couple
of years ago, they
said oh, we're going
to act on this finally.
At Berkeley, there
were four members
of the IPCC team,
Inez Fong, Kirk Smith,
Bill Collins we're all part
of the core team on campus
and the Lawrence Berkeley Lab.
And so we were told, yeah,
you're about to get the award.
You're going to get
the parking space.
And it's totally Berkeley.
And they absolutely
delivered what they said.
We got a parking space.
Nobel laureate bike parking.
And you got to read
the fine print,
parking not reserved
for IPCC contributors.
So the very few
times I go there,
there's like 16 student
bikes in a huge heap.
It looks like some sort
of twisted metal thing
from The Matrix.
But it is very
Berkeley-specific.
And so, Berkeley did us proud.
Our lab is sort of generally
thinking as interdisciplinary
as possible, as we can
about climate issues.
But we still come from
a technical perspective.
And so every now and
then, our forays into--
I'm not going to
call it economics.
I don't want to
even claim that--
but sort of financial
engineering, I would describe.
And so one of the things
that we came up with
was a way to finance energy
efficiency and renewables
something called PACE,
Property Assessed Clean Energy.
It's basically pirating the
simplest idea out there,
that municipalities
around the United States
often lend money
to property owners
to underground transmission
lines and repair sidewalks.
And so we borrowed this
idea, set up a company.
16 states passed laws to
enable PACE financing.
And it's worked relatively well.
But it has a critical flaw.
And that is, to get
municipal money,
to invest in renewables and
efficiency, both things that
make sense, you have
to own property.
And that means it is
inherently a regressive policy.
It borrows money from
all of us to pay off
those who are better off
because they own something.
And I'll come back at
the end to the halting
steps towards this
just transition,
or a socially equitable version
of a change in this really
critical problem.
Since then, our lab
has expanded the work
we've done with governments
around the world
to help them think through how
to do planning for an energy
transition.
And this has really been
the most interesting feature
for me.
My kind of complex
systems background,
interest in basic
materials science,
be it for new batteries,
or heat pumps,
or whatever the
technology fuel cells
as we're looking at the time.
But it's really
how to synthesize
that into complex enough
models, but also models
that can be translated
for work by governments,
by nonprofit groups, by activist
groups, by the private sector.
And I'll give a few
flavors of that as we go.
And we've worked with a
whole range of governments--
I just put some flags of
a few of them up there--
in places that have made
interesting strides.
And I should highlight
that, it may not be obvious,
we hear a lot about China.
And I'll come back to China.
And we have Mike
Danielson and others
in the room who
have real expertise.
But in terms of places like
Kenya you don't hear about,
Kenya is, in some ways, the
Silicon Valley of East Africa.
Morocco is the only
country that legitimately
went to the climate conference
this past December in Poland
and we're on target
to meet their 2050
goals-- the only country.
And why it's in Africa,
it's an interesting story.
And Malaysia has a
really interesting story
around decentralized energy.
So, there are some
really curious leaders
emerging in this field.
And that will get me into kind
of the core part of the talk.
And that is we have to make
this great energy transition.
But we are moving too slowly.
And the things that
have caused some
of the most interesting and most
rapid progress, some of them
are obvious.
But I will do sort
of a take on them.
But even though I assume that no
one here who came to this talk
in the first place-- who is
in Cambridge, at Harvard, MIT,
and various places--
needs any kind of a
primer on climate change.
But we all have somewhere in our
family tree, that crazy uncle
or aunt, who doesn't
believe climate change
and has 9,000
arguments that they'll
trot out over
Thanksgiving dinner
until you pass out from
tryptophan poisoning.
And it's their argument why
climate change isn't happening.
And one of the interesting
aspects of that
is that the climate community
on the science and engineering
side is very dedicated to our
models and our increasingly
complex models.
And while I'm as guilty as
anyone, one of the challenges
is to try to be able
to encapsulate climate
change in a model-free way.
And you can look at a given
heat wave, or this, or that.
But you can always say,
well, 80 years ago,
100 years ago there was
a similarly bad event.
And so, one thing
that I use and urge
anyone who has that sort of
troublesome aunt or uncle
in your family is
a wonderful NASA--
you can download this
from the NASA website.
And what it's going to show,
in I think 28 seconds or so,
is a series of synthetic
images taken each point
during one image per year when
the sea ice over the North Pole
hit its minimum.
And that means it could
be late August or early
September, depending
on that coldest moment.
And so, this is a critical
part of the story.
Because these are simply images
taken, no modeling involved.
And what you're going
to see is not only this,
but a graph and millions of
square kilometers showing
the amount of ice.
And so, those of you who have
watched Chasing Ice and now
Chasing Coral, I highly
recommend both of those.
But, you see, there's
some fluctuations.
But starting out
in the late 80s,
a little bit less than 7
million square kilometers of ice
at its minimum in
the late summer.
There are some warmer
years, colder years.
I think I debated Bjorn Lomborg
in '96 at a kind of a peak.
But you see, we have, in a
very steady, secular way,
lost about 50% of the ice cover.
And for those of you who
have seen Chasing Ice know--
very graphically and it
should make sense physically--
you don't just lose area.
You compact volume.
So you're losing a
dramatic amount of ice.
And again, in a
modeling-free way,
that's a pretty good slide
set to just play back
to that annoying
relative who insists
that they're going to tell you
all the reasons why climate
change is due to other things.
In my world view, though, one
of the hallmark events that I
think will go down in history
even though the recent history
we've seen has been
a little challenging,
is the fact that
we've had so far 24
of these COPS, these Climate
Conference of the Party
meetings.
But before the Paris one, this
is called the famous event
where we got this
wonderful agreement.
In 2014, President Obama
and Premier Xi met.
And they essentially said, this
189-country negotiation, this
is a pain in the blank.
And we're just going to
do a two-party conference.
After all, we are the G2
of messing up the planet.
We are 40% of global energy
use, 40% of global pollution.
If we come to an agreement,
it will really change things.
And in fact, that's
exactly what happened.
The agreement was
bizarrely asymmetric
from a political
science perspective.
President Obama pledged to cut
emissions by a third by 2025.
China promised to peak
emissions-- d emissions,
DT is equal to zero.
But they didn't say if that
was going to be a 2% or 200%
over the current level.
And of course, the US
has now backed off,
to put it mildly, the Clean
Power Plan that Obama proposed.
China, on the other hand,
that gave itself until 2030
to peak emissions, is going
to peak emissions sometime
probably in the next
six to seven years.
So China's going to meet its
target much earlier and much
lower than anyone forecast.
And so, a really
interesting mix.
Of course, these promises that
were made at the Paris Climate
Conference are things
that we've committed to
and haven't done yet.
And that's part of the problem.
But what happened is
that I then evolved
the work I was doing
from just at Berkeley
to a larger federal role,
first under Secretary Clinton
and then under Secretary Kerry.
And so, we worked in a variety
of capacities, in my case,
as science envoy working with
North African, sub-Saharan
Africa, and East
African, and Middle East
countries on their energy plans.
It was a wonderful time.
At the end of it, you get
kind of a wonderful letter
from the president
thanking you for trying
to be a liaison
for good planning
and bringing science
to bear on the problem.
But then of course, the US,
we had a little election.
And that election
didn't go well,
certainly from my own
perspective on things.
And so, it was time for me
to depart the administration.
And I, at home,
said you know, I'm
not going to keep serving
under this new president.
And my wife said, well
does that mean you'll
be around the house more?
Which I wasn't sure was a good
or bad thing from perspective.
But my kids said, well, dad
if you're going to do it,
there's only one way to do it.
You have to tweet it out.
And you have to tweet
it out in ways that I
learned from my children.
So, my younger child said,
well, if you're going to tweet,
you have to tweet 6 AM
California time, 9 AM East
Coast time, middle
of the day in Europe.
And you have to tweet
your message out
in a way that will have a
few interesting features.
So, I tweeted out my message.
I'm the son of a historian.
And so I had quotes from various
presidents of both parties.
I thought I was
being pretty clever.
No one read the letter
at all because I
didn't have a little cross
tick embedded in my message.
And that's when I started
to really listen to my kids.
Not only should I do it
early in the morning,
but then my younger
daughter challenged me.
Said, you have to have your
most famous friend retweet it
within a few minutes.
So that got more tricky.
I thought and thought,
who do I dare approach?
Who do I ask?
And so, I did ask my most famous
friend if she could retweet it.
And she did.
And, you know, by the
end of the first day
according to my daughter, I was
trending for nine nanoseconds.
Taylor Swift, by the
end of the first day,
it was just kind of an
interesting process.
And so, that put me back
into my day job at Berkeley.
And thankfully, a number
of other parts of the world
have moved on very steadily.
It's really hard to
meet our climate targets
without the US engaged.
Because if we look at business
as usual path for emissions,
if there is the
business as usual line,
you can just see if the
US and China collectively
don't get their houses in order,
we are not going to make it.
There's lots of arguments about
how you can have the treaty
work, and blah, blah, blah.
But in the end, these
two major players
are going to have to
really make progress.
And what was agreed to in
Paris wasn't just fueled
by a lot of good wine--
although it helped.
It was a remarkable
transition, and the idea
that we were on a pathway
in terms of billions of tons
emitted and in terms of the
temperature change we were
on a pace for, the
orange, or red,
or whatever that
color up there is,
that's what the commitments
made by the US, China, EU,
and everyone else were
going to shave off.
Now, those are
pledges made in 2015.
And as I said before,
only one country, Morocco,
is actually on pace
to get anywhere.
So, talk is certainly cheap
and paper, apparently,
is even cheaper.
But that was what we all
committed to, shaving a degree
right off the top.
And remember, we have
already warmed the planet
by one degree.
So it's not that we have
two degrees of room.
That was the negotiated,
we must cut our emissions
by 80% or more to
keep emission rise
less than two degrees
given that we've already
warmed by one degree.
And so, we were there.
And really, what
countries committed
to were the so-called national
commitments, the NDCs.
And they add up to this.
Some countries pledged to be
much more energy efficient,
some to do renewable energy,
others to protect forests,
wetlands, a whole variety
of very eclectic things
were proposed.
And the job of the
Conference of the Parties
is to really hold
us to that fire
and hold us to those targets.
And right now we are
not doing so well.
But the Paris climate meeting
also did something else.
And that is the--
the red is what we committed to.
But it was such an
enthusiastic meeting
that a very unlikely set of
some European, and the United
States, and many
developing nations
said this two-degree
number, that's not enough.
We need to keep
emissions lower still.
And one real failing of the
science community-- and I'm
as guilty as many
colleagues-- is
that we didn't go to
this Paris meeting
with models for how to
go much lower in hand.
A few groups had them.
And people trotted out
proposals that they
had written to agencies
that didn't get funded,
or whatever else,
and to say well,
we were thinking
about going lower
than that 80% cut in emissions.
Very few of the
academic community
was ready to step up while world
leaders got together and said
two degrees, that's the goal.
But we're really after
one and a half degrees,
the so-called High
Ambition Coalition.
Because that sounds better
than Low Ambition Coalition.
And in fact, what
happened was we
need to do everything
in the gray.
Those are all additions.
We need new science,
technology, in a whole variety
of areas, new policy mechanisms,
new behavioral tools.
But six months after the
Paris Climate Accord,
my boss, Secretary Kerry
at the State Department,
led the US effort to
pass the so-called Kigali
Accords that were
signed remarkably fast
and then ratified right away.
And those called for
about another half degree
to be cut largely
through refrigerants
and some industrial processes.
But it shows you how
quickly this whole system
can change, at least on paper.
And you have to make good on it.
Now, you don't have to
be too technical to note
that if two degrees
requires getting emissions
very near zero, getting
to one and a half degrees
is going to require scenarios
that go carbon negative.
And this has opened up all
kinds of dialogue around,
do we invest in
geoengineering, do
we invest in
smarter agriculture,
do we invest in healthier
soils, rivers, ecosystems
so that the natural world
can suck carbon down?
So, there's a fascinating
and very complex
discussion about how
to actually do this.
But it's a really
critical story.
And so, if I stop
there, I would have not
done any of the details.
But that's what we all promised.
Of course, the US
backed out, which is
why I resigned my federal job.
But what gave us hope
that you could get there?
And for me living
in California, it's
really this remarkable
story that if you
look at electricity use per
person in the United States,
it's been rising
in California, not
so different than the
rest of the country.
And of course where California
took that dip and the US
took that little hiatus,
that was the OPEC crisis.
And the engineering-savvy
folks will say well, wait,
an OPEC crisis is about oil.
But we don't run our
power plants on oil.
We run on coal, natural
gas, nuclear power,
and some renewables.
And so, what happened?
In fact, the economic slowdown
resulted in less demand.
But the real thing that
happened, in my view
in California right during
that little plateau,
is that California set up a new
state agency to start planning
around energy
transitions modeled
very much after some work that
had taken place in Europe.
The Energy Commission took off.
And instead of seeing
electricity use
just simply rising per person--
and there were well
thought out arguments
that if you wanted to grow your
economy, energy use must rise.
In fact, a sort of unfortunate--
very famous, but unfortunate--
economist, anthropologist at
the University of Michigan--
I won't name him, Leslie White--
he actually said that culture
evolves as the amount of energy
consumed rises.
And in fact, you all
on the east coast
may have your doubts about
California in terms of culture,
but by doubling
and tripling down
on residential, commercial,
and individual home
energy efficiency,
California stopped
electricity growth per person.
And it has remained
that way for decades.
There are some
interesting details
that are worth hashing out.
But that's a remarkable process.
Per capita we've leveled out.
But of course, we have
a lot more capitas.
And so we need more power.
But that is a wholesale change
in terms of economic thinking.
And it leads me to
one of the first kind
of undiscovered
observations for me.
And that is, this kind of
data enables a whole bunch
of much more
interesting planning.
But it also reveals
one of the problems.
And that is that
while we know that we
need to meet this climate
target of reducing emissions,
one of the far two general
observations for me
is that humans are
very, very poor
at doing any
decision-making that
doesn't seem to involve money.
And when I was in
Princeton, I had
the office next to a now-Nobel
laureate in economics.
He's not an economist.
But we had huge problems
because on the Carter
there was Dan Kammen and Danny
[? Koneman ?] side-by-side.
And we never got our own
mail or messages or anything.
But he, among others in the
behavioral economics world
really went on to think, how
do we develop other metrics?
How do we think through how
we're going to assess features?
And the fact that
nature does not
care about money means this
whole dialogue is incredibly
difficult. That doesn't mean
that a carbon price alone
will solve our problems.
But it's incredibly
difficult to get there
because what nature really
cares about is carbon emissions
and suck-down, so the net
flux of carbon and time.
And unfortunately, we are
doing ourselves no favors
until we can find
a way to translate
nature's currencies
of carbon in time,
and perhaps land use and
water into financial terms
or translate our financial
terms into money--
I mean, into these
natural units,
we're not going to get there.
So as an example,
many places have
done strategies in California.
We set a target for
20% of our energy
to come from renewables by 2010.
We missed the goal
through a party, got there
three years late.
Our next goal for 2020
was one-third of energy
coming from renewables.
And we are already over that.
California will probably in 2020
somewhere between 37% and 39%
powered by renewables.
That is amazing in itself.
And while every jurisdiction
has a different definition,
California does not count
large hydro or nuclear
as a renewable.
You can agree or disagree that's
just the bookkeeping California
chose to.
Our 2030 goal was 50% powered
by renewables by 2030.
But senator Kevin
de Leon and others
worked to pass a bill,
Senate Bill 100--
100% of our energy from
clean sources by 2045
and 60% by 2030.
And California is
certainly on path
to meet that incredibly
lofty-sounding goal for 2030.
Now, this leads me to not only
talk about these climate goals
that I've done most of the
talk so far about, but also
about the real
secret sauce in this.
And that is that
a number of places
related to discussions that
have now led to the Sunrise
Movement, to the Green New
Deal, to a new bill that
now has Republican and
Democratic support--
sponsors at least-- in
the House and Senate,
to start having a
revenue-neutral carbon price.
All of these have led to
a much bigger discussion
not just about climate
change, but about equity.
And I really want to sort
of hammer on that as we go.
Because I actually
am amazed we've
gotten as far as we have without
making a more just version
of this transition possible.
So, some of the things that
have happened in the California
process along the
way are interesting.
Leading up to this, 10 years
ago we started with an effort
to say all new homes
built in California
after 2020 must generate as
much energy as they consume.
So, some mixture of energy
efficiency and rooftop solar
is kind of the
poster child for it.
But it could be heat pumps.
It could be ownership share in a
wind farm not on your property.
A whole variety of things
have gone into this.
Which, when we initially
proposed this nine years ago,
people thought
were impossible, it
has passed its
law in California.
And now we get
construction companies
saying we only have 11
months to get to this target.
And we say, well, you
could have come along
with the process and the
discussion ever since.
And we're getting all
kinds of clever proposals
for what to do in a home
that simply can't have solar
on the roof because of trees
or a place like Pacifica
with a lot of fog.
And we're finding
interesting proposals.
Our equivalent of Star Market
in California, Safeway,
has now proposed they
would host solar.
Your home doesn't
have it on the roof.
But you have an ownership
share in that solar
they host on their building.
And it's part of your property.
So, there's lots of
things going on there
to sort of think through
how to do it differently.
At the same time that we pass
this one, it is now law--
and it was considered a reach--
there was an even bigger reach.
We passed, at the same time,
that by 2030 office buildings
of indeterminate height have
to also be carbon neutral.
Now, we know how to do this one.
But we do not know
how to do this one.
But in that go-along with
an innovative strategy,
California's actually
adopted this as well.
So it's a really
interesting mix.
Another version of
the story about how
do we convert our dialogue
to think not just about money
is something that several
places in the world
started to highlight.
The California
version was to say,
let's not just have a quota
system for clean energy.
Let's also do it for our fuels.
10 years ago we started
to work on this.
Almost everyone
who thought going
to clean fuels for vehicles
were thinking biofuels.
I was certainly part of that.
I wrote a paper that was widely
used to set a standard for it.
We went on 60 Minutes
and a variety of things.
And that rule basically
said, phase out gasoline.
Move to biofuels.
Except that you have to
do the cradle to grave,
the lifecycle analysis of
are those biofuels actually
sustainable?
Well, it turns out, of
course if your biofuel comes
from urban waste
from Boston, probably
it's a good thing
to use it for fuel.
If it comes from cutting
down Amazonian forest to then
grow soy, not so good.
And so, what California did was
adopt something called the Low
Carbon Fuel Standard.
And it said that if gasoline is
our benchmark in terms of grams
of carbon per megajoule
we have to take
into account the source.
And so, if you move
to Midwestern corn--
just look at the
blue for a second--
it's somewhat better.
Sugar cane is
quite a bit better,
ethanol that's made from
dry materials are better.
But none of them are home runs.
They are a few percent better
than gasoline in lifecycle.
They don't solve the story.
And in fact, there's
a vicious debate
going on around the green, which
is called the Indirect Land
Use.
And it's a very controversial
economic part of the story.
But there are lots of fuels
that are unambiguously better.
And so there is a
future for biofuels.
But as we all know,
there's been a push
into electricity, which has
really changed the game.
And I'll come back to
that in a little bit.
So, when I mentioned
this timetable,
we need to get to roughly
80%, or 90%, or even
100% decarbonised, depending
how sort of optimistic
you are by 2050, that's
not the whole story.
The other story is encapsulated
in this paper from which
Christina Figueres, who was the
chair of the Climate Process
and now she's head of the
European Climate Foundation,
highlighted.
And that is that every year
we go by with increasing
emissions, that's the tan line.
Of course, it makes
our peak higher,
so you have to reduce
emissions more.
But that's not my worry.
I believe we can beat this
down for the technologies
we'll be talking about
in the next few minutes.
The worry, though, is
that if we keep that 2050
goal as our serious
goal, which it must be,
then the slope of these lines
really becomes the worry.
The blue line, or whatever
that turquoise color is,
a 3% decarbonisation
sustained for decades.
The rust-colored one is
4% and the red is 5%.
And the problem is that we're
talking about not just one
or two years.
We're talking about decade after
decade of sustained innovation.
And the two
best-documented examples
are that California for about
seven years maintained 3%.
And while China's
energy demand grew,
they cleaned their mix so
dramatically that they also
averaged about 3%.
But no places
averaged the 4% or 5%.
And so, the longer we wait to
really start this in earnest,
the more the slope of this
line becomes the real challenge
in the process.
And that's really the issue.
And so, the other far too
general or sort of undiscovered
observation for me is that we
used to think of the energy
system as a supertanker.
So it takes-- the
analogy is not only oil,
but also takes miles
and miles to turn.
But more and more, we need
to think about it somehow
as a supertanker
trying to be a startup.
And how do we mix
the culture of this
is the biggest investment we
have in terms of infrastructure
on the planet?
And we need to change it
dramatically, quickly.
So, in the last
10 minutes I want
to highlight some examples.
And I'll do them
very quickly in terms
of some of the
waves of innovation
that have really given us some
tools for decarbonisation.
The first one is my favorite
most complicated graph
in the world--
maybe not the most complicated
graph in the world,
we'll leave that
for astrophysics--
but the most complicated
graph in my field.
And that is a graph showing
the progress in solar energy
on the material science side.
So, this incredibly
busy picture just
shows, for the traditional
big silicon cells
to smaller blue, the
crystaline ones, to thin film,
new emerging technologies to
the reds, new [INAUDIBLE] bytes,
and quantum dots,
and organic cells.
You're seeing the best
efficiency of a whole variety
of technologies with the
laboratory group that
held that record at the
time, and yes, the slope
of that line over time gives
you one metric of innovation.
And thankfully, these newer
entrants coming onto the scene
have higher slopes.
They're racing more rapidly.
Very exciting.
And it's this mixture of
technology push, new innovation
funded by governments, by
companies that gives us
a really diverse resource.
Meaning, there's many
different solar technologies.
Back when I started
this, when I started
working on this a
long time back when
I did my first summer of work
at the US National Renewable
Energy Laboratory,
there was really only
in the purple and the blue
that were seen as competitors.
Now all of these are looking
interesting candidates.
That, plus increasing
manufacturing largely in Asia
and markets growing around
the world-- first in Japan,
and then Germany,
and then California,
and now many places--
have led to kind of
a famous picture.
And that is this thing
called the Learning Curve.
And this is loved by people
who think about applied energy.
I think it's loathed by some
of my economics friends.
But the idea here is, notice
this is a log-log plot.
No apologies made.
So, price on the y-axis and
order of magnitude changes
and production on the x-axis,
in log-log space you get
a so-called power law--
this is Moore's law--
where we see a very
steady decline.
For most technologies
that are mass produced,
you get about a
20% drop in price
every time you double the
amount in manufacturing.
If you trust it, you
can then forward price.
You can give subsidies.
You can give incentives
so that we manufacture
and deploy more,
banking on a lower cost.
And solar has done
this remarkably well.
So, when I started
working on this area,
solar was $0.40 to
$0.60 per kilowatt hour,
depending where you are.
Now we have projects going in
initially in the Middle East
and now elsewhere,
solar at $0.03.
People said that was impossible.
Then in, first Saudi
Arabia, and then New Mexico,
and now Mexico, and now
Chile and the Atacama,
we have solar projects going
in for under $0.20 a kilowatt
hour, commercial cost.
And this is just transformative.
And that diversity of
technology I mentioned
means that there's all
kinds of amazing innovations
to come if we keep deploying
to give us demand pull,
and if we keep investing.
In fact, right now there
are transparent solar,
there is solar that works
off of the indoor light,
so you can have solar on your
roof, general electricity,
recapture and solar
inside a building.
We have thin and flexible solar.
We have technologies that
are really interesting.
We just hired a
professor at Berkeley,
and her specialty
is wearable solar.
So, your jacket is solar.
You can charge up devices.
I mean, it's a
fascinating world.
Almost none of it was
forecast some decades ago.
So, these learning
curves are wonderful.
They are heuristic.
There is a debate about them.
I'm writing a book right now
called The Learning Curve
to look at the mix of
technology push and aspirations.
And if we look at them,
they're generally sloped.
You can see the
photovoltaic, 1 PV.
There's wind,
there's NOx controls.
And then there's
this nuclear one.
And that's a problem.
So, if these are
learning curves,
I don't know if you'd
call that an unlearning
curve, a forgetting curve--
I'm going to get in trouble.
But that's the data for the US.
Now, you might posit that the
next generation of molten salt
reactors, of traveling
wave reactors,
of small modular reactors
will change this entirely.
And it might.
And I am a professor
of nuclear engineering.
But the actual data shows
that in the last few decades
of US installation, nuclear
prices have been rising.
And that is a huge worry.
In fact, I won't even
go into the story
of when nuclear
was first brought
to the market in
the United States.
So, there was a campaign
to make nuclear attractive
to homemakers, women.
That program had the
awesome name, Atom and Eve.
I'm just going to move right
along past Atom and Eve.
The new player on the world
of energy is in fact, storage.
And storage, while it's
much newer in terms
of the diversity, has the
same interesting range
of learning curves, from lead
acid, batteries, and cars,
to nickel metal hydride,
to lithium ion batteries.
And we spend a lot of
time with our colleagues
at Imperial College,
and Cambridge,
and elsewhere examining
these learning curves.
And actually today,
storage is improving
as fast as solar ever did.
And that brings me to the
last part of the talk.
And that is that we now
work with governments
to build models of
their power systems
to think about what
investments in new transmission
lines, in energy storage,
in energy efficiency
will you need to reach
a variety of targets?
And so right now,
the green are places
where we have active models
in use by governments.
And the blue are places where
we've promised and committed
to building a model
of the power system.
And for the
electrical engineers,
this is a so-called
capacity expansion model.
It is a beast in
terms of computation.
I won't get into
any of that here.
But we've had some really
interesting lessons come out
of this process.
And the biggest one is that
as these new technologies have
emerged, we have
discovered a whole variety
of interesting new
ways to do things.
So, for those who have
have been to Kenya,
this is the Ngong
Hills Wind Farm.
This wind farm was the
first wind farm in Kenya.
There's lots of good wind sites.
It was placed here
because the Ngong Hills,
you can see them from Nairobi.
And specifically,
you can see them
from the offices of
the state-run utility.
And so, you can see
them in operation.
There was real learning
and experience.
And Kenya has now progressed
to be this incredible climate
leader.
Of course, with some
investment support
by countries I won't mention--
United States and China--
there is now an effort to
build a coal plant in China.
And so, we will see about that.
The other interesting feature of
this history of mass production
and technology
innovation evolution
is that there are
lots of areas where
we didn't plan for solar to be
the opportunity that it's now
become.
So, sub-Saharan Africa, a $25
billion dollar a year industry.
Very expensive
over its lifetime,
but very inexpensive to
bring home a little lantern.
But then you're
committed to buying fuel.
Well, the range of
small solar products
that initially looked like just
glorified flashlights that then
became flashlights that
have built-in radios,
and flashlights that now
get better and better
at a whole variety
of tasks, mean
that we've taken those
incredible costs decline
curves.
And the fastest form
of new energy access,
not powering a whole home,
but device by device,
is now-- we call
Pay as You Go Solar.
So this, is basically
you take the device home
with often no down payment.
On trusted mobile money, you
make daily or weekly payments
online.
You bring the device home.
And the data science
and IT aspects
have just become fascinating.
So, in a big project we
did with the World Bank
we studied this process.
And as an example, this
was an initial sample
of 1,000 homes that had
these devices in them.
And we looked at what people
were going to have to do.
They were going to have to pay
about $0.50 a day on average
over a year to own the
devices I just showed you.
So we started to gather the
payment histories of people
and look at the state of
charge of their batteries.
And we observed oh, here's one.
They're paying it off just fine.
But here's one where they don't
seem to be using it at all.
So, we collected here were
those financial histories
of the 1,000 or so
dots on the graph.
The blue ones are all
people who were paying off,
and at the end of
the year they paid
enough to own their device.
The red ones are people who
started to pay, whatever else,
but ultimately
didn't pay enough.
And the company that
provided it turned it off.
And some of these
stories are just amazing.
What we started to
do a few months in
was to send text
messages to anyone
whose device wasn't working.
It said, can you
tell us what's wrong?
And they would text back
oh, yeah, it's not working.
And we asked where it is.
Well, it's actually
under the mattress.
Well, you know, the solar
panels don't work well
under the mattress.
Or it's outside, but it's
covered with cow poop.
And so we send
text messages back,
doubling the usage
rate in six months.
And so they ramped up.
We still had about 8% failures.
But remarkably, ramped up.
The demand rose.
Companies began to
build other products.
Now you can take
home televisions,
DC-powered refrigerators,
a whole variety of devices
to make the mixture of those
solar panels, and LED lights,
and little batteries work.
And then there's big batteries.
To meet California's
climate goal,
we used this model, this model
called Switch I mentioned,
to examine what would be needed.
And we found in
California is we're
going to need a lot of storage
to come online, both long term
seasonal storage
like reservoirs,
but also storage that works with
you over the course of a day.
And through that, we
wrote a requirement--
that now Germany
has copied as well,
and now Denmark is writing one--
where this is a new
type of battery.
There's actually an
amazing professor
here at Harvard,
Michael Aziz who works
on one of these flow batteries.
Unlike the several
thousand cycles
in your cell phone,
this flow battery,
it's a sulfuric
acid liquid battery.
This one is powered by solar.
And this has millions of cycles.
And so, you can change
the story to remarkably--
and this was one of
these early installations
to provide storage under
the California grid.
The other story of the
grid is really interesting.
And that is as we install
more and more solar,
we go from a demand curve
from the middle of the night
that's pretty flat-- only
students are awake, we think--
and then the more
solar we install,
California's on a path to
have a million solar rooftops
by the end of next year,
which means roughly one 1
of 15 households.
But when you install
more and more solar,
the net demand, or the demand
left over, gets hollowed out.
So we now have a situation
where there's very little demand
that we forecast to be on the
grid during the afternoon.
But everyone comes home,
and you turn devices on.
So you get this
incredibly sharp ramp.
And this is called
the duck curve,
where we will have this huge,
not only need for power,
but over this short
period of time.
Well, another way to
look at that duck curve
is that every power
engineer over about 40
knows that peak demand
comes in the late afternoon
when devices are on
at home and office,
and on the hottest summer days.
California now forecasts
our peak demand
will be at night in the
winter because of low solar.
And so when you look at this
curve a little differently,
this is an excess of
green during the afternoon
that if you have storage such
as the commercial one I just
showed you or your
electric vehicle,
you could sell power back
and make that available later
in the day.
And so we're seeing this
kind of remarkable thinking
about how to dual-use
your electric vehicle.
And the economics, once the
vehicle prices are the same,
are remarkable.
At three $3.50 a gallon, it's
about $0.14 per mile to drive
your car.
But at rooftop solar, those
commercial rates, it is $0.01.
So more than an
order of magnitude
cheaper to drive your
electric vehicle.
Now, the vehicles themselves
need to be [INAUDIBLE]..
But we're getting
pretty close to that.
And the last thing I'm going
to highlight at the end
is that we not only have
Tesla thinking they're going
not only sell you all
cars, but electric trucks.
And we have things
like charging lanes
where you inductively charge
as you drive down the road.
And instead of
parking places where
you must pull in,
charging pads that
can be moved from car to car.
So, instead of running out to
your car in the parking lot
at Google, or Amazon,
wherever else,
the charging pads just simply
move from vehicle to vehicle
to charge you up.
And if we don't do
it, guess who will?
This is China's map not
only of the 2.3 million
EVs they have and the
279,000 charging stations.
But on their national
map they also track
the number of electric vehicles
in the United States, EU,
and Japan.
So you can bet they are
thinking hard about how
to make this happen.
Now, the last
thing I want to say
because I'm right at the end
is that one of the challenges
that I mentioned
the beginning is
that if we don't make
this transition one that's
much more inclusive, we make
our job impossibly hard.
And the climate scientists,
clean energy engineers
like myself, I think
have done a terrible job
of making this inclusive.
And of course, if you provide
subsidies for electric vehicles
or for solar, whether you can
justify those learning curves
or not, you are subsidizing
the rich with the poor
to put these technologies
in place, right?
And when you have
socialism for the rich
and capitalism for poor,
that is not a recipe
for an inclusive process.
And so we've done a fair amount
of work to look at this story.
And so we used a large
60-million rooftop data
from Google, did
a lot of machine
learning that I won't
get into the details,
to look at the roofs, to
track the solar panels,
to look where they are, and
to use census data to examine
which homes they're on.
And so the sad
part of the story--
I'll just skip, I'll just
go to the conclusion right
at the end--
is that even when you
control for income,
solar is 30% to 40% more
prevalent in neighborhoods that
are white, Caucasian-dominated
and 30% to 70% less prevalent
in Latino and African-American
neighborhoods,
even when income
is controlled for.
And so, if we don't think
about ways to do this better,
subsidies for
community groups, ways
that landlords and renters can
share the benefits of going
solar, we make this transition
incredibly difficult.
We make this story about a green
transition near impossible.
So, I'm going to leave you just
at the end with the last part
of the story that came out
of not only the IPCC and then
the climate
conference in Poland,
but what has now becomed
discussed as this Green New
Deal.
So, one of the
things I was asked
to do by Governor
Schwarzenegger was
to build a carbon footprint
tool, a calculator, that will
allow you to look at your data.
And so we did that.
We built versions that
are available for homes,
businesses, and schools.
It's called
CoolClimate.Berkeley.edu.
The data sets are wonderful.
There's kilowatt hours used per
for each zip code on average,
natural gas consumption, goods
and services, transportation
and food.
And at the end of the
day, what you discover
is that the ability
to think differently
is kind of remarkable.
So the last page when
you go through one
of these online calculators,
this one that we built,
is that it tells
you your footprint.
That's the top part.
But then this take action page
is the thing that's really
caught a lot of attention.
When we release a new version,
we get like 100,000 hits a day.
So, this take action
list tells you
all the things in our database
that you, the homeowner,
or school, or
business didn't do,
and what each one will
cost you or save you
in money in carbon terms.
And so we have got this
sort of hilarious process
where people will
use the calculator.
And they quickly go and look at
the most equivalent homes-- so,
this is called keeping
up with the Joneses,
where you look at I have
five people in my home,
it's a 3,000 square foot home.
And people look
down the database
to see what do other homes
that are equivalent to you,
both in terms of size, number
of people, geographic location.
And then go look at
what people did here
and look at the stories
about which of these things
people really took advantage of.
And so, this process we now
do for all of California.
We do it for Germany and Japan.
And zip code by zip
code, this is actually
down to the parcel level.
We see all kinds of
interesting dynamics
in terms of people
learning from each other.
And I want to end with
that one because one
of the critical things that's
emerged from the climate
process is that as fast or as
slow as we are in this process
is certainly a function
of new technology
and of innovative
policies-- hopefully
more progressive
than regressive--
but policies that find a way
to empower individuals to make
decisions, whether
the individual is
a homeowner, a school, a
business, or a municipality.
And if we don't find a way
to really enable all of that,
we make this job of this just
transition in this energy
process near impossible.
So, I know I raced at the end.
But I wanted to
highlight the degree
to which this sort
of information system
has really changed the story.
I would love to hear questions.
I'd also love to hear examples
of things that have worked
and not worked in
your own experience.
Was it hard or easy to do this
or that, to weatherize, to buy
into this and that?
So, I hope that you'll
share some of those.
And I want to thank you
all for coming tonight.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, and thank you for
your insightful talk.
And I would like to ask, since
we mostly focused on California
and other countries,
what do you think
the challenge will
be for us to expand
to other states and
the United States?
- So, great question.
We're actually in a better
spot than one might think.
Over half of US states
have these clean energy
targets, these RPSs.
President Trump did cancel
the Clean Power Plan
that I thought was a
wonderful piece of policy.
But we have seen coal
use drop dramatically.
So coal that was over
60% of US electricity
is now down to the 30% range.
The entire value of
the coal industry,
the Capex of all US coal,
is under $50 billion.
Meaning that Jeff Bezos and
Bill Gates could buy two of them
if they wanted.
So, the idea that we
are wedded to coal
anymore is certainly
not part of the story.
That opens up an interesting
next part of the story.
And that is that in some
parts of the country--
California as an example--
gas is the dirtiest
fuel possible.
And it's one we know
we need to phase out.
But in other places, the
biggest change they can make
is to move from coal to gas.
And so, you get this
interesting mix state by state.
The Clean Power Plan-- something
that I would recommend whoever
decides they want to get the
US back on track put back
into effect right away--
said each state needed to
decarbonise by a third relative
to its own baseline.
It didn't require states that
have started late to battle
with New York and California,
that started earlier on.
But it's given us a mix.
And so, actually I think right
now we were in a good spot.
If we do get the Clean Power
Plan restarted in some form,
we'd really be there.
And the sad part of the story
is that the Clean Power Plan
actually called for
$8 billion dollars
to be provided as retraining
and retirement money for people
in the coal industry.
And the sad fact
is that I do not
believe the coal industry
will ever get as good an offer
as it got under the
Clean Power Plan, which
means that the retirements
that will ultimately happen now
are going to be uglier and
more painful for working class
Americans.
And so, I think the US could
rapidly get back on this path.
But I fear that unless we really
do get this kind of Green New
Deal mentality, we are going to
stick it to the least able to
deal.
And that's the people who have
been in coal mines for so long.
So, great question.
I'll go faster afterwards.
Sorry.
- I'm going to take
you up on your offer.
This is the third iteration
of my solar backpack.
And I suspect I'm
the only person here
who is carrying solar?
- Nope, I am.
- Good.
What it is a $10 solar
charger and light,
and a piece of plastic.
And I use this as my headlight
on my bike as I bike home.
$10 retail, online,
anywhere around the world.
What one billion plus people--
- Without access.
Retail price, $10 billion,
which is less than a day's worth
of what we spend on
the global military.
Right?
So, that's one thing.
- I'm asking you to jump
to the question Just to--
I'm in agreement, but yeah.
- I will give you a question.
But I'll give you
another resource.
Geotherapy, right, which is
the marine carbon project
in one case, this is a way
to bring down the carbon out
of the atmosphere.
And Boston Cambridge happens
to be a hotbed of information
about this.
But it's not happening
at Harvard and MIT.
- OK.
- I had an entirely
different comment to make.
- OK.
- I was wondering where the
long-term you thought it made
any sense to change the
curriculum of free college
education-- and what stage
is not quite clear to me--
to teach these things
for the long term
and teach the
teachers to produce?
- Right.
So, I mean, the
obvious answer is yes.
And thankfully, Harvard has
one of the most innovative
professors of science education,
and that's Eric Mazur.
And I have seen just
remarkable things come out
of the cooperation that
they and many other groups,
but Eric's team
in particular, has
done to think about how to
integrate these programs.
One of the most interesting
things at the climate
conference, and much of the sort
of attention to this incredibly
eloquent and powerful
Swedish 15-year-old
has been the real demand
for schools striking
over not getting
better climate action,
not getting better education.
And when the kids in
schools are asking for it,
I mean I would say this is
kind of perfect territory.
And so, I would absolutely
think that's the case.
You know, every science
museum, every school,
there's huge
opportunities to really
make this a core part
of the curriculum.
So I'm hoping-- and there
are some really good efforts.
But they are individual pockets.
They have not become
the ubiquitous, better,
environmental and
science literacy
that many people
have called for,
and so Pedro Noguera, and Eric
Mazur, and a number of others
have been remarkable on this.
But I think this is absolutely
critical to this process.
- Thank you very much.
Great talk.
Clearly you're doing
wonderful things.
I do have a concern.
And I'm interested
in your insight
into whether locally green
policies in California
contribute to it being so
expensive to live there
that no one can move there.
So they all move to
Texas, where they're
forced to run their air
conditioner for nine months out
of the year.
To locally green
policies, is there
a risk that there's a net effect
that they're globally brown?
- Yeah, so it's a really
interesting question.
I mean, this is part of this
whole doing a just transition.
And the story is not the same
in every single neighborhood.
But the California
data, the data
from Portugal, the
data from Denmark
is very strongly indicating that
high residential prices are not
due to higher cost electricity.
In fact, California has some of
the most expensive electricity
in the country but some
of the lowest electricity
bills in the country.
And that's largely
because per kilowatt hour
is more expensive, but by being
very aggressive on efficiency--
as is true in Florida,
Wisconsin, New York,
it is not just a
California thing--
that overall story
has been a plus.
And that leads me
to one other thing
that I cut out just because
I obviously ran long.
And that is that the
data is unequivocal
that clean energy
technologies generate more
jobs than the fossil sector.
Now, that's not because
it is superior in any way.
That's because if you're
building a new technology
base and one where you're
not paying for fuel,
it's not surprising you get
more jobs per dollar or RND
invested.
It's that you're
building a new sector.
But the fact that
you're not putting
a huge amount of the
money into the fuel
means that you're investing in
people and companies and IP.
And so, we have incredibly
diverse data sets
that show hugely
larger job creation.
And my worry is that places
like California that have really
doubled down on
it, where over 40%
of all US venture
capital in clean tech
goes through California, are
going to do well in this deal.
But when-- I won't name
states, Mississippi--
and others that are not exactly
on the leading edge finally
decide to go there,
that green jobs dividend
will been eaten up by
those who went early.
And so instead of being
a penalty to go early,
there is a big benefit.
But this has to
be more inclusive.
California is less than
1% of global emissions.
And so green in California
but not spreading the policies
that we have, the
policies from Bangladesh,
from Kenya, from Denmark,
from places that are really
jumped way ahead,
from Morocco, means
we're not going to get there.
And so, I think we are
highlighting a key worry.
But the places that
have acted actually
have done quite well in
the deal on that basis.
California is too expensive
for a lot of other reasons.
That is everyone
chooses to live within--
myself included-- within
20 miles of the coast.
And the key residential
hubs are also
the places for these
booms of new companies.
Housing prices are crazy.
We have graduate
students at Berkeley
on food stamps as a result
of unaffordable housing.
But it's not due
to clean energy.
The worry is proper.
- I just have a question.
You were talking about
the Clean Power Plan.
I was wondering what you think
about the Regional Greenhouse
Gas Initiative as
compared to that.
- Yeah, so, you guys are
under a program as well.
The challenge here has
been that while RGGI is now
improving a fair amount, the
carbon price is very low.
And the worry is that
if we had started
this process of launching
carbon prices early on,
a low price now that ramped
up very slow would be fine.
And the contrast would be this
new, bipartisan bill introduced
in the House and Senate is one
that calls for the carbon price
to start higher than
California's current price,
which is about $12 a ton.
Start more like $20 and
go up $10 every year.
And that reflects
how much we need
to move more quickly because
we've really delayed.
And so, you know, RGGI is good.
The ETS, which has also had
its ups and downs, figuratively
and literally, is
also a good thing.
But I think that the
lesson we've learned so far
is that a carbon
price is critical
because we need to
have this dialogue
between financial
metrics and others.
But the places that have
moved ahead globally
have not done so relying
on a carbon price.
It is one arrow in the quiver.
It's silver buckshot,
as Al Gore likes to say,
it's not a silver
bullet unless the price
gets so high for which
the politics may really
become challenging.
So it's a neat point.
- Thanks for coming
and speaking with us.
A friend of mine,
an economics grad,
is moved to Brazil to work on
deforestation in the Amazon.
And I'm hoping to join her and
learn a little more down there.
So, on a micro level, what are
some strategies that can help
on the deforestation forefront?
And on a larger level,
the election of Bolsonaro
is definitely a very
bad news for the Amazon.
- Yeah.
- What can we do on that
larger level other than shake
our heads?
- Well, so there is no silver
bullet answer to that question,
right?
But I mean it is
interesting that Brazil
got a huge amount of early, very
positive press for investing
in sugar cane ethanol.
And the early sugar
cane was largely
on land that had been that had
pulled back from former rubber
production and others.
But it's become so profitable
that sugar expansion
and related crops,
digging into the Amazon
has become a huge issue.
And so when you look at
that graph I went over
in terms of the carbon
content of liquid fuels,
it's just striking.
If you really do use
bio waste, then there
is no environmental
penalty you should
add to that liter of biofuel.
But if you're cutting
down rainforest,
it turns out that you would need
to run your ethanol production
for over 100 years to
pay back the carbon that
was standing in those
trees in the rainforest.
And believe me, this is
not a happy conversation.
So, if everyone in the front row
is a current food farmer that
decides to go into
biofuels and you decide
you're only going to
collect [INAUDIBLE] waste,
and so you have
no carbon penalty.
But Alyssa here
says, you know, I'm
going to convert my current
corn production into biofuels.
I'm going to do it sustainably.
I'm going to bless it, I'm going
to-- all these /It's is going
to be great.
But someone elsewhere says well,
she's no longer producing corn.
I'm going to get
into that business.
And increasingly-- that's
in Indonesia, Brazil, Congo,
Malaysia--
then you're cutting
into forests that
had a much better
value as forests then
as ethanol producers.
This conversation does
not go well in Brazil.
And I have-- sort
of my mentor is
the father of the
Brazilian ethanol
industry, an amazing figure.
He was the host of the
Rio Climate Conference.
And this is an area where
we're on sensitive ground.
And so finding a way
to lead with the facts
and the numbers is my physics
tribe way to do things.
But this is a really
hard conversation.
And so, working in the area,
what you guys are supposed
to do is what I recommend.
But finding a way
to compare the life
cycle, to cradle
to grave analysis
is a critical part of it.
But that is that's
a seed change,
and so we don't
have a lot of years.
But that's a critical
part of the process.
That's hard.
- My question was
around corporate world.
When the CDP put
out a report that
says that 71% of
carbon emissions
are being generated
by 100 companies,
and we're talking about
in this sort of countries,
and governments, and
things, what are you
or others in your field
doing to help educate
and these companies transition
away from this carbon emission?
- So, this is
actually an area where
my economics colleagues can give
much better answers than I do.
And this is the
place where I would
argue that carbon pricing
can have the most value.
The fact that carbon enters
our economy through us
through so few spigots--
you mentioned the
kind of, you know,
on the order of 100
companies-- that's
a remarkably small number.
So arguments to regulate
carbon at the user end
may be the standard
policymaking tool.
But doing it upstream
makes much more sense
in terms of of efficiency,
even if the increased price
gets passed down.
The challenge, of
course, is that if you
increase the price for
production for those companies
and don't find a way to
give back to low income
people around the
planet, then your policy
might be for the
planet but it's not
part of this just or
equitable transition.
And so, one of the features
that I'm hoping the dialogue
around the bill--
I really like the
bill in many ways
that's in front of
the House and Senate--
is to not just rebate
all of the revenues back
to all Californians equally--
I said Californians,
sorry about that--
to all Americans equally.
But to actually
say no, we're going
to give back an extra share to
the lowest income Californian.
So, what I would do is a
hybrid of the Ocasio-Cortez.
And that would be if you are
within 200% of the poverty
line, I would give you back
your share but also a share
taken from the top
0.01%, and use that money
both to give back to
low income Americans.
And a part that's
not in the bill,
there is no provision
to harvest money
from the bill for research.
And I would argue if you want
to do this, you give back a lot.
But you also need
to hold a fund.
And we've seen this work
President George Bush started
ARPA-E, the Advanced Research
Projects Agency for Energy,
modeled after DARPA.
It's been phenomenally
successful.
But it's got a budget
of $300 million a year.
And if you want to make
a dent here, you know,
we need to at least get
to the level of what
the US spends on pet
food research, which
is over a billion dollars.
And that's just to start, right?
So, great question.
- Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]